and now it's time for bombing reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review
monsters this is it
this was a thoroughly enjoyable film
with good animation decent writing and
very good amounts of 3d production I
thoroughly enjoyed it oh my god this is
the greatest movie that I personally
have ever seen in my entire life I would
have been horrible
oh my god this film this epic
masterpiece is the greatest film that we
as humans have ever produced and I have
ever seen in my entire life
I mean Zoe how was that after the
description predictable there is a woman
who grows to be very large
she is hit by a meteorite that contains
all sorts of scientific supernatural
powers and but she has taken to a secret
government location well monstrous
things happen fighting must dress I mean
monster it's real monsters there is a
big blue bar that looks like crisp
Sparkle toothpaste a cockroach man I
tell you that's just silly
the missing link between man and fish I
suppose and they are out to stop an evil
alien that has four eyes would imagine
that and I guess I don't want to give
anything else away with the governor to
bittitan yeah well they I do I give
everything else away all right the
gigantic woman goes inside the giant
spaceship and stops the evil aliens from
taking over the world and thus
everything is returned back to normal
well what else do you want from me do
you want to just rewrite the whole thing
oh gee goes into the giant spaceship
runs lots of running but the alien in
tracks her in this laser cake but she
breaks out of a cage and suddenly she's
shrunken down to her normal size oh so
the other monsters hop on board to try
and save her but she ends up saving them
by being small and then suddenly
becoming large and then becoming small
get another wait that did that she was
overdoing logs as she became small dingy
becomes large again I've no no I mean
she wasn't born alright so and logically
makes it okay so she starts off small
becomes large gets smaller than becomes
large again I never realized how complex
this movie was so she blows up the ship
or however that sound if that goes and
they are all falling to their deaths but
then Insectosaurus comes because now he
is a butterfly
oh wait a minute I didn't tell you about
psycho Soares did I all right let me go
back to the beginning no no no no not a
bit wrap up okay so they all live
happily ever after I stole my 3d glasses
because I am thoroughly a horrible
person and then I came home and
masturbated would you like a reenactment
of that no this is that kind of the
glass is saying change change is a
particle which could change change is
upon us changed you've changed something
must have well I can't just find out
doing it pressure what you want me to do
something like change
can I change is that what you would like
well no I'm not gonna do it
piss off I'm going to go masturbate
and I won't be thinking of you